[Musik]
Aber das ist immer noch meine Heimat, hier sind wir
wieder kommen wir zum Problem des Vaterlandes und
Eure Exzellenz, ich bin der Unterschied
Davon abgesehen weiß ich ganz genau, dass ich das verstehe
Ich bin Russe, ich liebe mein Land, aber so
zu sagen, dass ich Putins Regime nicht respektiere
Ich liebe es, ich habe nie für ihn gestimmt
Ein echter Journalist sollte immer
im Gegensatz zum aktuellen stehen
Behörden Journalist Wachhund der Demokratie und
Ein Journalist muss unparteiisch sein, das ist alles
Dem komme ich nach
[Musik]
alle Petrokratien streben danach
Der Imperialismus spielt am Ende verrückt
[Musik]